devo tagliarmi i capelli lo so devo
tagliarmi i capelli e ho avuto una
settimana molto difficile Non so se
avete notato non è uscito neanche un
video perché ho avuto l'influenza ho
avuto l'influenza visto che erano 2 anni
che non me la prendevo perché non avere
l'influenza proprio a dicembre che il
mese dove si monetizza di più quindi non
far uscire neanche un video per altri
consigli di business iscrivetevi al
canale bella tutti ragazzi io sono Favij
e oggi siamo tornati con un video Quindi
è già una cosa positiva Perché è uscito
una mazza quindi non è più con un nuovo
video ma con un video È è già state Boni
se mi vedete un po' spazio solo perché
mi sono ripreso da stamattina ho
riniziato subito a registrare però di
base mi sto riprendendo comunque mais
Fatto Attenzione importante ma hai fatto
come due settimane fa perché oggi vi
racconto cosa è successo
sigla
cioè non c'ho ancora la Sila per questi
uomini fare faremo una sigla di un
argomento Ma dove vi racconto un
aneddoto tipo quello del Canada
Fatemi sapere se secondo voi è meglio
che io giochicchia Rocket League nel
mentre o se gli va bene due settimane fa
vado a trovare un amico a Milano e si
raggiunge in serata un terzo una persona
un amico che non vedevo da un sacco di
tempo ma poi da tantissimo Ok ci
raggiunge io poi quando non vedo una
persona un sacco di tempo sono proprio O
mio Dio come stai Ma cosa è successo nel
mentre Raccontami di quando hai venduto
e le azioni di Tesla su Twitter
ho amicizie in alto parte gli scherzi
sono amico arriva chiacchieriamo un po'
e poi certo punto mi fa oh Stasera
andiamo a far serata io
intramontabile ottantenne nel corpo di
un 26enne nella mia testa ero tipo
io gli ho detto Dai perché no E quindi
ci accingiamo a far serata nel Milanese
Ok quindi a Milano il sabato sera quando
puoi andare a far serata Non puoi
camminare pieno di gente un disastro
Quindi io a maggior ragione perché avete
visto il discorso del essere fermato che
non sono proprio totalmente confident
immaginatemi in discoteca quindi non che
non ci sia mai andata ci vado ma è molto
raro andiamo Innanzitutto in una prima
discoteca Milanese tutto tranquillo Poi
che torni qui fa no no no mi piace
andiamo da un'altra parte entravo in una
seconda discoteca Milanese molto nota io
tratti tutto questo avevo la mascherina
e il cappello quindi non mi si poteva
riconoscere Ok bellissimo tutti quelli
che quando entri in discoteca con la
mascherina il cappello ti guardano
Questo è uno che pensa che ci sia il
coniglio sta con la mascherina ragazzi
non è che tengo la mascherina so che non
esiste il covid come voi che sicuramente
Avete studiato che mi togliessi la
mascherina sarebbe molto più difficile
per me la vita commento sappiatelo
Quindi ovviamente proprio nel stavo
scherzando però immagino abbiate capito
Comunque andiamo avanti
discoteca e sto mio amico Fastweb Allora
partiamo dal fatto che ha 35 anni quindi
ha 10 anni in più di me e e vive come
come io non vivevo a 18 anni cioè nel
senso che esce tutte un pazzo pazzo
incredibile Non so come tu faccia però
Sei pazzesco entriamo in quest'ultima
discoteca dove lui a tutti sti agganci
incredibile fa quando esci che siamo
fuori esce questo
comprando Ok che era il Pilar e fa
venite venite che c'ho il tavolo perché
io l'avevo detto che tu Nico guarda che
se io vado in discoteca non ci posso
entrare nella nella nella pista da ballo
mail devo andare nel privè ma non perché
me la tiro non me ne frega un cazzo
neanche della discoteca Semplicemente
per il fatto che se mi levo la
mascherina in mezzo a tutti Io faccio un
raduno quindi non è per me una giornata
di svago Ma è un ansia quindi dobbiamo
andare in un privé Ma no tranquillo e
vado sempre in privè esce pranzo ci
porta Vai tranquillo lui avrebbe fatto
comunque nel Iniziamo a fare Non sta
serata Pub La bottiglia che arrivano
beviamo c'è un certo punto io dico
Guarda
questo mio amico Guarda
debba do erano le quattro del mattino
vado che domani devo fare delle robe
vabbè vabbè vabbè me ne vado e la serata
finisce quindi questo è tutto tranquillo
Ora passa una settimana ok arriva il
venerdì dopo questo è il venerdì dove
c'è stato il gamesweek Ok quello stato
che musica Milano non so se ci siete
stati ora arriviamo a fine giornata sta
anch'io Ermanno che il mio personal che
è quello del video di Home Eagle che
dice Ciao surri surri Ecco no lui il mio
attuale personal manager arriviamo a
fine serata stanchi più ti chiamo un
attimo sul divano un certo punto mi
chiama il mio amico quello la settimana
prima dove eravamo andati a fare serata
mi chiama e mi fa Lory sono di nuovo a
Milano per cui non è di Milano tutto
questa ti conosce tutte le discoteche
Milano ma non è di Milano per farvi
capire poi sono a Milano di nuovo Esci
stasera vieni con me che andiamo a
farsela Guarda
Pinuccio chiamiamo così non non è serata
per un S rata solo lavorato sono stanco
ma poi lascia stare no vieni perché no
guarda guarda Ermanno lo guardo gli dico
ma senti ma tu per caso non è che ci
avresti voglia di andare a far serata ti
chiedo è se vuoi fare serata ma non
penso lui mi parli fa
tu c'hai voglia e io tu c'hai voglia sai
quale sarà Quale vuoi quelle situazioni
qui ti Spalletti con un tuo amico a un
certo punto dici vabbè dai andiamo
facciamo troviamo insieme la complicità
e la voglia di far valere questi 20 anni
finché ci sono alla di qualcun altro mi
va bene arriviamo Ok siccome stavolta
non abbiamo cambiato tre discoteche
siamo là direttamente in quella dove
l'ha mandato l'ultima volta quella a
colpo sicuro andiamo lì e Viano
arriviamo davanti a questa disputa era
alle 2 di notte ok E qui succede la cosa
incredibile
discoteca ovviamente tutto col cappello
ma riconoscibile chiamami amico dico io
Ermanno Siamo qua fuori dove sei Sono io
mi fa entrare Io sto andando in un altra
discoteca perché c'è un amico che fa il
compleanno sono venuto qua per te un
altro po' che dove hai arriva fuori
quelli dell'altra volta vede meglio
Ermanno ed era circondato da queste
ragazze queste modelle modelle che lui
chiama al tavolo so ma io non so bene
come funzioni l'ambiente della discoteca
Ok però credo che i p AR
facciano entrare queste modelle per
fare bella presenza all'interno Daddy
sulle se non lo so come come spiegartelo
Comunque perché di solito chi entra Non
lo so sentite vabbè Che cazzo prendo
queste tipe e ci fanno stasera stata
incredibile non ha nulla a che vedere
con la volta scorsa che stavolta selat
assurda venite mi ci fa entrare Ok ci fa
entrare
Ci porta allo stesso tavolo dell'altra
volta mentre ci porta al tavolo Ermanno
mi fa l'orecchio Lori Oh ma cioè vedi
che queste robe qua di base costano
Tanti li facciamo a Noemi Ma va mica si
fa cioè questa è una roba e amicissimo
del mio amico che sta per arrivare Cioè
nel senso amici non è che si fa Non è
che stiamo entrando come come gente che
paga cioè e siamo ospiti del mio amico
Cioè proprio sono amici Come si invita
si te mica ti faccio per capito quello
di sua Sì sicuro Eh certo sì mica l'ho
pagata l'altra volta ci sono entrato
perché ero amico Cioè nel senso che
trova figurati Entro quando arriviamo al
suo tavolo e siamo io Ermanno e ci sono
cioè questo piar pranzo e ci sono tutte
ste ragazze delle quali né a me né a
Ermanno ce ne fregava un cazzo da Non ce
ne frega niente del Pilar cippa se ti
chiamava Che cos'è che volete bere
Intanto
io lo guardi gli faccio Guarda non sono
proprio un Bevitore quindi Scegli tu a
me non mi frega niente Poi guarda c'era
il menù C'erano un miliardo di drink Tra
l'altro in discoteca faccio questa
Piccola parentesi il drink meno costoso
in questa discoteca costava tipo €400
non so scherzare costa €400 c'è una
conquista ma si balla si beve stiamo tra
di noi nel frattempo arriva anche il mio
altro amico quello che doveva venire già
da subito arriva nel frattempo arriva
anche un'altra bottiglia erano già la
seconda bottiglia ballo balliamo beviamo
un po' fino a che alle 4:30 del mattino
io guarda Emily di guerra
Andiamocene basta perché è tardi allora
vado dal Pia da pranzo quella
organizzata robe Guarda Grazie per la
serata comunque noi andiamo
sei stato super gentile Lei mi guarda e
mi fa e tanto tutto questo io ero
ubriaco marcio Cioè nel senso ho bevuto
io non bevo mai così tanto però quelle
situazioni è rarissimo già che non
andavo di fretta da una vita e mezzo
nella la settimana prima però vabbè
Avete capito tu per ubriachi Nino ero
ubriaco ubriaco punto lui mi guarda e mi
fa grande Va bene ti preoccupare Senti
ma posso ordinare un'altra bottiglia per
le ragazze e lo guardo gli faccio
Ma che cazzo ne frega Mica io devo
pagare io se gli ho detto proprio così
ma proprio una nonchalance incredibile
Lui mi guarda e mi fa e teoricamente Sì
allora sì pagare tu
cosa c'è No è stata proprio questa
faccia nel senso lungo non ho risposto
niente ma l'ho guardato mi dire Ma che
stai dicendo e lui mi guarda e mi fa No
no Ma aspetta Forse tu non sai come
funziona adesso te lo spiego noi
portiamo dentro i ragazzi e poi loro
pagano per tutti
Ma esattamente Quando pensavi di dirmelo
a questa cosa me la dovresti dire questa
cosa noiosa visto che non lo so quanto
Guarda se sono 1200 sono €1000 di conto
sono non posso darti mille stai fermo
che lo guardo gli dico in tutto questo
l'ho fatto una mia mente mica gliel'ho
detto che non lo guardate
Aspetta un attimo ti ho fatto quello che
ho fatto un giretto così mi giro verso
il mio amico quello 35enne che amico suo
amicissimi sono questi due non lo prendo
con tutta calma come Silente si rivolge
alla ribotti faccio questo ci vuole fare
pagare €1000 di bottiglie tutto urlato
perché la discoteca musica un casino
cosa dobbiamo fare il mio amico mi pare
li fanno tutti ubriachi tranquillo Lore
anch'io l'altra volta era così anch'io
ho pagato l'altra volta
hai pagato l'altra e Quando pensavi di
dire quanto hai pagato l'altro mi stai
portando in discoteca tutte le sere
paghi €1000 E dimmelo che ne so io no
vabbè incredibile Comunque io disperato
Non sapevo non ce l'avevo neanche io non
avevo i soldi cioè nel senso io giro con
un giro con tutti sti soldi giro con la
carta prepagata per farti capire perché
sono paranoico quindi non si sa mai che
qualcuno mi può te non c'ho neanche io
non c'ho la carta di Non ce l'ho la
carta di credito lo sapete perché sono
nato in Canada non mi hanno dato la
macchina proprio perché non ho la carta
di credito Io c'ho quella prepagata per
tutte le evenienze con questo mio amico
in tutto sto casino mi fa cioè io non
gli ho detto non avevo i soldi ho detto
Mi ero limitato di lino che ci vuoi far
pagare le bottiglie cosa così tranquilla
l'ho pagato io l'altra volta pago io
anche adesso non ti preoccupare
e lì il mio cuore rinsavito grazie Non
ho proprio amico gli ho detto Senti ma
dimmelo che paghi subito ti dicevo No
guarda non vengo non sarei mai andato a
saperlo non sarei mai andato a spendere
€1000 ma siete pazzi Cioè ma non sarei
mai andato Non vado più in discoteca
questa domenica almeno ci ho iniziato a
fare discorsi da Sere Guarda se andavo
in discoteca non entriamo la guardiamo
da fuori perché non ho intenzione di
spendere €1000 per una roba del genere
Cioè non è che non che non ce li abbia
semplicemente come sono soldi buttati
nel cesso perché effettivamente non vale
€1000 quella roba Ecco è un po' il
discorso che avevo fatto del sui vestiti
non l'avevo fatto tipo 3-4 anni fatto
discorso ma li farò un video a riguardo
io do un prezzo a tutte le cose che
faccio Quindi se guardo una maglia di
Gucci non è perché c'è scritto Gucci da
pago €1000 per me quella maglia una
maglia carina te la pago 25 se poi me la
vendi a €1000 ovviamente non te la
compro è per me un tavolo in discoteca
ma io non so nell'ambiente Quindi potete
tranquillamente in disaccordo Ma io non
lo pagherò mai mille perché per me vale
tutta quella roba che abbiamo vissuto
può valere ma il massimo ma proprio
perché sto buono 100 ma proprio perché
sono buono
esagerato perché lì la gente spende per
far vedere che spende cioè Qual è la
figata sto dando i soldi per far vedere
che ce li ho
Wow incredibile Sei il numero uno Fra
non vi Insegnami essere figo parte quei
video Spero di riprendermi totalmente
Scusatemi se sto video parlato un po'
strano se sono un po' strano Vabbè
miracolo che io abbia Sei riuscita a
farlo perché ieri stavo di pezza però il
piede è che hai lasciato un bel commento
e mi piace e noi ci vediamo come sempre
in discoteca perché insomma mi trovate
lì come sapete tutti no
[Musica]